you're playing Norman Bates one of the
most famous psychopaths in in film
history and and killers but there's
something oddly attractive about that
personality what is it I really don't
know there's also something oddly
attractive about killing people and
getting to you know it kind of feels
good on set there's a there's a cook
know what you're saying that you enjoy
killing and killing again there is a
cathartic quality to stabbing someone in
the shower in this way the way that you
know you have a good cry about something
when you're upset or you shout at
someone when you're angry or you just
tell you get it you you get it out now
fortunately some people commit murder
and then they have to spend the rest of
their life paying for it you get to do
it as part of your job again and again
and again again and again and again and
then I would think then you get to go
home and I feel like you get to probably
get this great release from from getting
all of that craziness out of your system
exactly yeah I mean not that I guess I
should recommend acting as a form of
therapy but it is it is a it's kind of
fun I mean I'm gonna go you know see
what see what you think well no no I'm
not I'm not yeah I love that you came
out here and you're suggesting I get
into acting pretty what you're pretty
much saying is fine something you're
good at you know it's interesting
obviously part of the role is you you
need to dress up Norman Bates dresses up
as his mom you don't know and so that is
part of the role is you dressing up as
mrs. Bates is that something that feels
strange to you do you oddly get used to
it after a while when you're wearing
women's clothing
I would to say there's the same level of
enjoyment as as the killing side of the
role but but it is what an odd way to
put it I'm just gonna say I like wearing
women's clothing a lot but not as much
as killing people
well there you have it Freddie high bore
everybody know it was funny this year
actually because Vera and I who plays
Norma in the show and mother in the show
would often be walking around in
matching dresses you know we do kind of
switch in and out of scenes together but
it just took me a little getting used to
wearing the dress and you know keeping
my as you see now you know I'm sitting
like this - as I've been trained to do
you know there was a little more
indecent exposure the first couple of
first couple of goes out yeah and II
like what he says he just spreads out
lately
you know he's like and he makes sure
that his tie is pointing right down
under the glory land where else is a
gonna point like it's like a highway
sign yeah the producers had to take me
to one side maybe yeah well this is the
final season a lot of people not happy
about that it's a tradition I don't know
in this country tradition when you're
when a season is finally over and a show
has come to its its end actors sometimes
take something from the set as a momento
have you done anything like that yet I
think a lot of the stuff they wanted to
keep to auction off but I did manage to
steal like a couple of things know that
I should be announcing this now what
you've announced you enjoying murder and
you went on a great length so this is
nothing yes this really wasn't the plan
yeah but yeah I half inch to the
managers badge Norman has his managers
badge that he's very proud of I mean it
is half inch to half inch yeah we're
like sort of steel Nick - Nick is that
what they call it half inch it you some
people do over in Britain I think most
people would understand but I don't
think I've you ever heard that before
is it like a rhyming thing like for
pinched yes yeah yeah okay okay it's
rhyming slang riots
I enjoy the you know will the British I
mean I am British so I'm allowed to use
those phrases with this I love that you
need to defend your right to use British
phrases
you have every right I've just never
heard 1/2 inch I mean I have but
[Applause]
I have interested on my wedding night
I'm sorry I'm sorry
Freddie did you know what you were
getting into when you came on this show
like you're like this will be a very
urbane sort of thing in Britain yeah no
no and you shouldn't it's why you have
the better country
you